You're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself. There's been
a change in the image of thought. That's what it is. That's what it is. The internal structure
as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the subject.
So we're continuing, yeah, on our Derida turn from restricted the general economy, a Hegelianism
without reserve. Yes sir. And we're gonna see if Nate's gonna uh be the Hegel defender.
Yeah, I mean, clearly I'm going to be at certain. Also, it's not really directed at, hey, this is all
about Bataille, right? Like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah. So it made me want to read, but like, I I uh I can't
believe I hadn't read this essay before. Maybe it's just been such a long time because it's so much of
what we've talked about over the last few seasons. Like, it's it's thematized explicitly in this essay.
Um, yeah, the inhabitation of Hegel and this, you know, the slide that the sovereign offers in contrast to
lordships, like all of the thematics are directly there and in many ways I was like I didn't really
love this essay um just because it was so direct, right? Like it was so it was so explicit about its
focus on the implicit. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I know what you mean. I wonder does he do deal with Bataille a lot
elsewhere? Because like he gives Bataille credit here to the point where you think like Bataille's the guy
like he's the man, like like where like there's nobody like him. But I I don't remember reading
Derrida on Bataille elsewhere. I'm sure he does, but you know, Blanchot mentions yeah but I but in terms
of his sustained engagement. That's the other thing. It always it made me kind of want to go read
Bataille um because I had read Bataille back in grad school and the the version of Bataille that I got
was the sort of commitment to transgression which was also a commitment to the limit and I didn't
really right um I didn't find that terribly interesting. Yeah, like the preface to transgression
thing that Fukura like it also makes me want to go back and reread that essay because I'm like
hey maybe there's a pretty good essay. There's other stuff going on. I haven't read that in 20 years. I'm
sure. Yeah, um but also to read more Bataille like because back then I read like The Story of the Eye
which is a novel and and like The Accursed Share, I think, and there was it just didn't really click
for me because I just associated him with this like like I said this transgressive Saudian
uh right right version and it's like what what you have here is a much more supple version of
transgressive. I mean there's transgression here but it's not simply the overcoming of limits that
re-establishes other limits, right? Like and that the moment at the end I think is really interesting
where he's like I'm going to read Bataille against Hegel which is also against Bataille because Bataille
doesn't read himself against Hegel here, you know? Right um so there's that the interesting way in which
it seems like a lot of what he sees Bataille as doing is is directed at Hegel or at least um
if though Bataille might have seen it as a following out of a Hegelian thinking
he sees it as kind of a slide away, not a stiff arming and certainly not a negation, but an attempt
to slide away. So I mean there's something to be said in terms of the intellectual history that
you know you've remarked on before boo boo about like you know something happens in the 60s where
there's this whole group of folks that are like Hegel bad um and for whom you know Bataille is a little
bit earlier thinker is not really part of that right he doesn't he doesn't feel like he has to
attempt to distance himself although it does seem like Bataille's inclination to read within Hegel is
partially because at least this is the way that I'm taking Derrida's gloss on it is that Bataille recognizes
that to try to stiff arm Hegel is precisely to get caught up in the dialectic like if you can't you
can't oppose or negate or engage Hegelianism within the figure of of uh the the dialectic. Yeah um yeah or
or discourse and so the only thing that he can do is inhabit Hegel and then introduce a kind of laughter
or a kind of of comedy where like I mean, you know, one of the the things that Derrida returns to over
and over again is the labor or the work of of the negative and of the seriousness and it seems like
what Bataille does is point out the comedy or the laughter not to distance oneself from Hegel and
laugh at it, which is exactly what Derrida accuses more recent followers of Bataille of doing
right but to intimately immerse oneself in it and then allow Hegel to laugh at itself and it seems
like that a point of laughter that emerges is at the catch-22 of the of the master or of the lord
itself who in order to establish itself as lord must become subject to the recognition
of the slave and that becomes a the version of the negative which is a domestication of the
Absolute negative or of absolute erasure, um, so it's the harnessing of the negative to create something
positive, but then also too the positive that is created, a recognized identity as a recognition of
lordship becomes kind of hilarious because it's very clearly like it's it's a lord only through the
possibility of servitude to the net that to the need of recognition, right? Well, it's sort of a vulgar
fool's game, like if if all you're after is identity and mastery, you know, with the the sort of
constitutive failure, like the whole ethic is resentment basically, like in Nietzsche's terms, so
the this this laughter would be in service of redirecting that ethos or ethic in some way, and I think
Derrida is interesting on this within the 60s and and 70s here because like you said, Nathaniel,
he he basically says you need to inhabit Hegel's text in order potentially to transform or redirect
that ethic or ethos, which makes him clearly different from Deleuze, who basically wants a total detachment
like he he wants something violent like we need to we need to completely shove this uh down and foster
sort of a Nietzschean affirmation, um, and Foucault is sort of more in that vein as well
so Derrida is I wouldn't say more complex he's just taking a different um, a different line where
it's like well he's inhabiting Bataille who inhabited inhabits Hegel so I mean like it's like the most
Derridian thing I feel like you can do inhabit the inhabitor what's weird about this this particular
essay though is that he stresses at the beginning like there's this menacing influence of Hegelianism
that you have to inhabit in order to potentially to transform and then I feel like yeah like he's
mostly just inhabiting Bataille's text or Bataille's version of Hegel I don't see a lot of inhabiting
Hegel here I see kind of in a lot of places a caricature of Hegel, um, which again is not a problem in
itself but it's it's weird because elsewhere Derrida is like like in Glas is like his text is
imperceptible to the point where like you don't even know who's talking is it Hegel talking is it
Derrida where's the interventions like so this is like pretty like the intervention is clear Hegel's
the restricted economy Bataille and my version of Bataille and Hegel against Hegel that's the general
economy so it's like there's there's pretty clear demarcations in this essay and a pretty clear
distinction or difference between Hegel Bataille's Hegel Derrida's Bataille's Hegel right right
I I don't know I mean it's also important to say that that clear distinction between the restricted
and the general economy isn't a distinction right? Like I mean it is it's it's not like there's one right
that is subordinate to you know right the other or just a smaller case but it's it is the way that
we've talked about it the impossibility of rendering this non-relation you know and because there isn't
there isn't a thing called the general economy right? Like that that it's like this whole essay is about
difference you know yeah or as and the word here is sovereignty right? Like that's thinking
at the beginning right? It's different so there's there's a I mean because I I didn't really
I mean to me I I my sense in reading this was he's just trying to think through what Bataille
is doing right? Like that's it um, and so Bataille has chosen this path of engaging Hegel in this way
and Derrida finds it fascinating because where you get to is that you can't simply inhabit right? Like
that there's you you're not going to have a sense of the distinctions between the inhabitor and the
inhabited right? Um, right, and and all you can do is produce these like words you know that that don't
make sense but not because they are a terrain from a terrain of non-meaning so there's a way here for me
at least that like Hegel's not a bad guy here you know um, it doesn't seem like it it's like
the bad guy is and this is the thing that you say all the time boo boo is like the that like the bad
guy is the kind of consciousness that drives value that drives meaning that like organizes the whole
thing that Hegel has so totalizingly mapped out and is so fucking right about and like and so to that
extent will will never be done with reading Hegel um, and yet there's something else you know and and yet
but there's not a something else right? Like you always have to do those provisional things there isn't
an alternative uh to Hegel and certainly not a negation but in that sense it's like Hegel as the
diagnostician of consciousness is like totally spot on right? Um, so it doesn't seem like
doesn't seem like Hegel's the bad guy but it certainly seems like Hegel discovered the bad
guy which sounds like a very Nate thing to say right? That's right, right, constant reminder the bad
guy yeah right but it terrifies right he just becomes the name for it like the Hegelian phenomenology
just becomes the name for subjectivity consciousness the the uh reserve, you know, holding in reserve that
Little bit of the, you know, the the bet, right? Right? Like, as we were talking about, of like, the the value
Bet, yeah, I mean the the only thing that I really took issue with was the intervention where basically
there needs to be a point of contention here for this essay to work, where he says it several times
where like there's a blind spot in Hegel or there's like Hegel didn't read his own revelation like that
kind of like he didn't he didn't realize his own genius at certain moments in the text and I just feel
like it doesn't really matter. I mean, like, you pick a target and that's the target, but I feel like there's
so many points where Hegel's spirit or absolute spirit or several of his concepts in some way that they
basically, um, point to Derrida's version of laughter here or the sovereign, but here it's posed as like
the sovereign is like the blind spot that Hegel couldn't quite get to, like, right, in the lordship
I gotta jump in because Nate was Nate was almost smiling full-blown during that entire monologue because
he knew he lost his bet unprompted he just starts defending Hegel against a as of yet unarticulated
right, right, and and the reason I the reason I don't agree is simply like the project is what
the fuck is Bataille doing with sovereignty and yeah that's what it is. It's like, and so this this
concept has an emerge has emerged as an attempt to rethink lordship um and and all of the oppositions
to which one can pose one can pose to lordship are subsumed under that whole movement so that's why
the thinking of sovereignty as the equivalent of a thinking of difference like it's a non-concept it's a
not it can't do the work of opposing Hegel which is which is honestly to me that's what the essay is
sort of about is like hey here's a um a really deft effort on Bataille's part who realizes unlike many
that you can't critique Hegel um and that you don't need to right um and and so in that sense it's a kind
of it's a weird celebration of Bataille's non-intervention right um well it's not weird but I think that's what it is
it is this like Bataille has offered us a thinking that allows for you know something else that's not other
you know right right yeah and they can't go anywhere and they can't have a following that can't produce a
discourse that can't become difference even right like right right well go ahead I was just gonna say
that the what one of the things that was just sort of painting in the back of my head from about the
halfway point until the end was just it was actually in our last season on Heidegger and Heidegger's
reading of Nietzsche as resentment again as the vengeance against life or or vengeance against
becoming and it strikes me that you know as we've talked we've talked about Hegel being a thinker of
movement over and over and over again and it's really more of a sort of like the style of that movement
but in in reading this what was sort of
dangling in front of me for for a long time was just that um how important the function of recognition
is for the movement of of the master-slave dialectic or just the movement of the dialectic
itself that negation is a a is a reifying moment that is them in service of a kind of movement or is
in service of a kind of of production but it needs to create stilted snapshots of something it needs to
have a status or a being recognized now that the recognition of that being is always a failure which
then is going to move the machine but it just provides a very different orientation to the quite the very
question of of movement itself which which is to say like the question seems to be more this how does
being move or how does being change but you start with being and then think of within and always failed
being that allows it to move and it just seemed like so much of the I mean you know Derrida about
three quarters the way through maybe halfway through it's when he really starts to talk about the
language of recognition and then about three quarters of the way through about like just the thing without
the sovereign is has no need for recognition it has no need need for in fact it cannot in order to be
sovereign it cannot be subordinate to anything else and it cannot seek to subordinate including to itself
including to its own presence it can only the second part is the crucial part yeah right the far more
important part because that's where you know John you're called you're using the language of
difference here which I think is is right I wrote I wrote that in the margins but just to stick with in
the other language of just becoming yeah as well as in the not incomplete state of being but as the ever
self-overcoming or that as ever self-transformative never through a mechanism of negation or failed
recognition or and or better yet to say like insufficient recognition and then you know the question of the
movement of becoming is just a different question than the movement of being because it seems to me that
the movement of being is always subject to something like the paradox of like Zeno's paradox is when you begin
With a snapshot image of time and beings, it seems like movement is never actually possible except for in
the negative relief. You can recognize the difference between this state and that state, but the internal
internal structure of becoming is its own movement, whereas it seems like you have to get to the get to movement by a
much sort of clumsier
route, which is, by the way, the only route by which understanding has
to to move itself. But that's only if you're beginning from the need or the drive to understand the thing.
Yeah, I mean, my my own again this is why I I didn't want to defend Hegel here because it's not necessary, like
there's not a real point in like trying to uphold his version because I think the the intervention
is in some way sort of necessary and super interesting and I think really relates to like a lot of our
conversations about the overman as well as this this potential ethical transformation that has to
necessarily remain enigmatic and strange and a little bit mysterious without you know lapsing into
mysticism because it's like like I we said over text like if you were to comprehend the overman or even
attempt to comprehend the overman or sovereignty you would just fall back into the the Hegelian system
of you know comprehension recognition representation all of that stuff. The sovereign would become the
lord, right? Right, it would just fall back into lordship. But you also can't just abandon the project
right of like well it's just this thing that's in excess in relationship to knowledge, right? That's
hence the sort of produce more words and yeah and it's thoroughly systematic the way that
Derrida makes this intervention through Bataille. It's not just some careless like well we have laughter
we're gonna laugh at hey it's not just it doesn't just stop it oh it's not it's not laughing it's
definitely not laughing at no no no it's definitely not that. But again the only the only slight thing just
for the purposes of my project, you know, this doesn't necessarily like i'm not asking you guys to have
this thought but um it seems like a lot of people in order to make this intervention into Hegel they
kind of you have to stop at the lordship and bondage section, right? I mean like there's there's other
like they're not he's not necessarily interrogating spirit or absolute spirit and again I'm not saying he has
to but Hegel doesn't necessarily celebrate the understanding or the lord, right? I mean like
eventually as like as we all know the truth of self-consciousness is found in the position of
servitude, right? So it's like it's this whole recursive really weird circuitous process that gets us back
to this like ground level and I think you could argue that Hegel does offer something similar to
sovereignty. Now it's not it's not that it's not what Derrida is saying it's not the overman Hegel's not
offering some potential transformation of the dynamics of subjectivity. He's basically saying you don't get
to get out of it, right? So that's what that's the key difference between Hegel and Nietzsche Hegel and
Derrida Hegel and Foucault is that the French continental continental tradition is attempting uh to do
something different but I think that in some places they're not giving him enough credit like
it seems like what they're saying is like the lordship and bondage section like that's the
entirety of the Phenomenology or that the understanding right the dynamics of the understanding
that's the whole thing whereas like as we've said he's diagnosing the understanding um it's not just
a celebration of subjectivity or resentment it's like saying like this is to some extent an inescapable
structure of thinking or being here's how we can deal with it um but it's not a full endorsement it's
not a full-throated endorsement of those dynamics I don't think I agree and I think and I think that
Derrida and potentially even Bataille uh agree with that as well but I do think that it's it's fair to say
then though that the human subject subjectivity consciousness understanding knowledge are just
pseudonyms for the mechanism of revenge against life as becoming and that that I mean I think that
you're right Nate insofar as that sort of then lays out the field or the problematic of human existence
Yeah, I would say it this way: like it's like so what if Hegel's right right? Like I mean that the
critique is the critique is this and that I mean it's like what does being right get you right? What
does correctly diagnosing the movements of consciousness which like all of these folks are
granting like so what um and what does that offer and that's the project for Hegel right like that is
that's like we're going to understand uh the whole movement of you know not just understanding but the
whole uh um emergence of spirit through its uh various steps and I think this the idea here is
again like so like that's a philosophical project um and that what they're interested in is not a
non-philosophical, that's why he does that work on the poetic at that one point, uh, sort of early on
because that's like what Heidegger does; you kind of kind of want to say, like, Heidegger should have
pre-read his Bataille, right? Like that, you know, the poet, you got to do work on the poetic because simply
saying, uh, look at the, you know, figural dimensions, uh, figural iterative dimensions of of the poetic, it's
like versus the concept, that's not going to do it. That's that's fully subsumable in that, uh, oppositional
matrix. So it's like, oh, it actually is about having to inhabit the philosophical language,
right, which is what Bataille says. I mean, there's that that one chunk in there where he's like,
I, I have to, I have to talk philosophy though. It's not the right language.
And and it's like, yeah, that's that's the game. And that's where I mean whatever Bataille ends up
sounding really Derridian to me in this regard, but one of the stakes of that I think really is
and it's really hard I think for each of us in different ways to get our heads around this is
that Hegel's not a good guy or a bad guy or even a neutral guy, right? Like he at a certain level he's
not any particular thing, right? Like it is, it's one kind of engagement and that's where to me that
offering the different style of engagement I think the underlying question is what's so great about
being right about diagnosing the movement of consciousness? Like yeah, you know, or or why is
it overrun by a kind of representational ethos must must be adequate to the thing? It's like no, it
doesn't have to be right. Well that's the entire that's the kind of the the entire driving force, I
mean just at the level of the title from restricted to the general economy is that like within a restricted
economy whereby the way the restriction is marked by the necessity of conscious recognition, I mean
that's that that ends up being the sort of the core value that is held on. We should also we should
also acknowledge that the restricted economy comprises all of being right, like yeah, yeah, all like
everything, every thought, every movement, every everything, like anything that could ever be
can yeah, anything that could ever be considered a being right and by the way even more than that
anything that can be rendered as a right concepts, words, language, people, like everything. So that I mean
the the terminology is a little like because restricted it sounds like well it's a narrow area and the
general thing is more broad. It's like it's not all of all of ontology, all of metaphysics, right? So yeah so
yeah, it's quite large but it's still but it's still a it's everything. Yeah, every thing, yes, everything.
yeah, but the importance there is that movement everything. Yeah, even movement in terms of it sort of like
discreteness and it steps and it's right every thing is rendered according to a restricted economy
or according to you know the the the the machinery of subjective consciousness and understanding and yet that
is still despite how large it is that is still not the only economy that is still that is still an op that is
one operation I would even say one rhetorical operation among others. Now you can like the problem with
not the not the problem but the the frustrating thing about all of the other kinds of machineries and
economies is that they don't produce things which means that you can't you can't articulate them as
beings which means that you can't think about their you can't recognize them as understanding or
knowledges like and even you know even in my pronouns I can't start talking about them as thems
right but it is still like there's still that uh that that that general economy that's you know in this in
this essay is is the sovereign but you can also just call it you know the like the performativity or
invention illocutionary force illocutionary force difference just difference and the paradox also is that
Derrida's version of sovereignty here or difference whatever it's framed as an ontological condition
almost like a fact like this is this is how life works but it's so it's like this intimate thing but
it's also something that's like so far on the horizon that you can't even begin to conceptualize it
right or internalize it. That's right because you have right because you have well because as soon
as you start talking about recognizing or internalizing it then you've subjected it to
being and I think part of it I think part of the language of the general the restricted to general
economy is the record the recognition was let's hold on to that for a second the recognition that the
restricted economy is one rendering or one modality of the of a general economy right? Yeah, so it's
one way of inhabiting general economy which is sort of the ontological baseline the restricted
but the weird thing about the restrictive economy is it takes everything as its object
right so when a restrict the restricted economy takes the general economy as its object it renders itself
In its own image with as it renders becoming as being, so like you have to look at it from both ways, is that
being is nothing more than a rhetorical configuration of becoming, and then yet beings jam
is to render and configure becoming, and you can say that's why, that's why it's like, look, that the
restricted economy is only possible because, or being is only possible because of a becoming, so
becoming the sovereign as a condition of possibility for the lord for being, but at the other hand when
you're talking about becoming or sovereignty from the perspective of being, that's why it could only be
this thing out there on the horizon that you would call futurity or the overman that you'll never be
you'll never be able to be it and you'll never be able to even point to it exactly like, ah, there it is
there's some sovereignty, ah, but that's, you know, that's from the perspective of that, that restricted
economy of being, which by the way is the only economy is the only economy that you can, it's the only economy
capable of pointing, right, or demarcating, or when you could say you could you could also maybe say that
the restricted economy is a symptomatic collective response to the dynamics of the general economy
but that doesn't mean that you get to get out of it, it's equally constitutive at that point once you're
in the restricted economy there's no like there's no clear route out because what's in it is us as
subconscious subjects, knowing subjects, right? And this is why I think, yeah, good, it was striking to me.
There was one moment in there where he says that sovereignty is not even the condition of possibility
and that's often the terminology he uses in other places and this is like '67, right? This is early.
and you know a lot of times you think of Derrida as the condition of possibility, like non-knowledge is
the condition of possibility, it's like it's not even the condition of possibility, it's not, it's not
like there's a background affirmation of sovereignty that allows negation to work, right? Like it's, it's not
even that, it's, it's, it's literally nothing, and and that's, I mean, here's the thing where I think that
you know you're hard pressed at least to me you're hard pressed to make Hegel into a thinker who is
attempting to attend to that, right? Like he just, it's just not the project, right? Like, and for for someone like
Batai it is and for someone like Derrida it is and that doesn't yeah that's not to say that you can't
find that thing in Hegel, um, it's just that the direction and the focus and the disposition is one
that's just a different kind of disposition, like what are the rules of the game, right, is like Hegel's
question and he is so dramatically and perfectly answered it through movement of negation that there's
no alternative and yet the rules of the game come from somewhere or not cut that's even too strong of a word
it's not like there's an origin point, but that's not all there is or rather it is all there is
but you could facilitate a transformation potentially and that's sort of it's not even a train it wouldn't
even be a transformation, like that's where to me it's sort of like this isn't a overman, like we'll get there
one day, like we don't get there, there's no there um, that there's still all you have but all you have
but what you have is the inducing of a non-laughing laughter within the Hegelian discourse, yeah, right.
like that's all we're doing is these like chuckling moments where we're not laughing at we're just like
this shit's fucking crazy, right? Like that's it, that's the that's or we're laughing at ourselves, I mean
we can yeah I mean one thing about Hegel is it because it can become intimately personal and you
know sort of like the the laughing the eye laughing at itself for its desire for recognition at the
moment of recognizing its impossibility, right? And the preservation of the disturbility that it that it
requires, yeah that's right to like the desire to pursue preserve myself is the desire for my death
that's right right I mean that's where the end the end thing where he does this stuff
with this sort of contra Hegel you know in quotation marks contra but like he rewrites that that that
image of like through the the glance or whatever through the visibility he right rewrites that image of
preserving one's life right like that one must risk one's life but obviously in the Hegelian discourse
the lord must risk his life uh to be lord but he also has to live through it and that's the moment of
laughter it's like oh yeah we know how this game works right it's it's about the it's and and for me
what was really helpful was to realize the problem with the movement of the alphabon isn't really
negation so much it's the sublation move it's the it's the maintaining as well as overcoming right
the preservation component it doesn't allow itself actually to be sheer negation or absolute negation
or abstract negation it needs to like time capsule because if you actually did that right then i mean
because any moment of the dialectical machinery requires the stabilization of that which has been
Sublimated in order for it to persist if it were a sheer negation then you know if the sophists were
just simply negated there's no Socrates right right yeah but that's another one of the paradoxes I mean like
even you know at a at a biological level like in order to persist as an identity you have to be
constitutively constitutively open to the ruptures of alterity to the outside so there is no final
preservation of self even if that is the explicit telos of understanding that's right of master it
cannot it cannot have that telos as its ontological condition even if that's the sort of I don't know
what you would call it not a subjective telos but like even if that's the mechanism where understanding
wants totality or the master wants security and invulnerability right the only way for that to work
for him to persist is actually to be open to death to be vulnerable right yeah and to be vulnerable so
that that's just another one of those cute little Hegelian paradoxes right well like I mean but it
does and this is more in the spirit of Nietzsche's untruth and lying in a non-moral sense is that
it just gives you a like a particular vantage point on how silly or trivial or odd or derivative or unlikely
this drive toward truth or this machinery of under the faculty of understanding is from the perspective
of of life right because because this is none of this is a problem for life right because there
is no identity is not a problem for life because they're just straight up no identities like what
does it mean for there to be an identity outside of recognition or understanding and I was like that's
just like a non-starting term and then to then like say all right well you know understanding seems to
want this it's like yeah understanding and nothing else nothing other than this little peculiar almost
sort of like appendix or or or or like derivative effect of an otherwise purely affirmative world of
becoming it's like I want to understand things and you know like we part of the the operation of the
podcast and you know I imagine this is the operation of all our listeners as well as like our drive
toward that is this kind of insatiable life-sustaining curiosity but I think that's a relatively late
uh interpretation of of the understanding like the the the interpretation of understanding by curiosity is
a relatively late uh um appropriation a relatively late interpretation because I'd be with Heidegger
on this is that the desire to understand is the desire to fix to dominate to forestall death which is to
forestall its own life and you know like the very opposition between life and death is a false opposition
presumes that things are there to live and things are there to die whereas becoming you know the
concept of becoming has no real use for the very notion of a dead thing or a living thing
it's only ever life death right I mean this just comes back to the dynamics of resentment as well like
if the if the dominating impulse of all modern humanity is this sort of life depreciating
controlling drive um you know then then the enemy like we've been saying would be the human uh not
necessarily Hegel himself although Hegel certainly included but the enemy would have to be like
the entirety of our mode of engagement our collective mode of engagement you know since whenever since
maybe even the Greeks or you know since since we've been reading since the dawn of history like so
how I mean my only my only question the reason I'm invested in this in Hegel's project as opposed to
or you know alongside Derrida's and Foucault's is that like Derrida says at the beginning a lot of
people just want to kind of skip past it like okay the Hegel thing that's like scary and and I don't
know I feel like we've kind of gotten past that shit so let's move on to like you know relational ontologies
because that seems progressive and maybe that can foster a better a better ethical you know engagement
with the world so it seems like you know in the in the reach past a lot of the times you know even
if it's implicit even if you're not mentioning Hegel you're like going you're not only not going past
Hegel you're going like five steps behind him and you're getting caught in like some pre-Kantian
thing we're like well that's that's where I mean Derrida is really he's like turning the page on
philosophy usually amounts to philosophizing badly right like in other words thinking that you've got
the new thing and we've talked about obviously even the phrase relational ontology doesn't make sense
right like you have to do some work on like well if relations have a being then you've given up
the whole function that you introduced relations for in the first place um but but whatever I mean
the the flip side of a way another way of saying the thing that Nathanael was saying a second ago to
which you responded is like if that's all there is that kind of resentful sort of setting of that's
also not all there is which is to say the whole thing is also that silent laughter in the midst of you
Know, like, so it's also that, right? It is, it's not just this this sort of negative deprecating life
deprecating thing. It is also so that negative life deprecation. This is where I find Nietzsche really
helpful: that negative life deprecation is a form of life, right? It's a form of will to power. It's
just a different kind of life. So it's like, you know, what Derrida is doing here is he's like
you know, hunting down and and highlighting the laughing quality, right? Like, and that's to me
different than Hegel, right? Like, that's just a different disposition. That doesn't mean that they
are, you know, fundamentally or that they're even opposed or that one can't doesn't create the room
for the other. That's a different disposition, and honestly I think that that's the whole aversion to Hegel
thing is well, I I think that there's a there's a there's a tragedy to or a sadness or a somberness
or a burden of life for for Hegel to carry in the impossibility of like this moment that Bataille and
and Derrida are calling a moment of laughter. It seems more like Hegel's response to it as
a sigh and keep the machinery running and perhaps to elevate one's consciousness of it to yeah, like
some kind of absolute conscious where I am conscious of or I understand the mechanism of
the understanding and then I just sort of more or less resign myself to it. But you know, like, let's
let's say, you know, I mean, to do a faux genealogy here, that the under the mechanism of the of the
understanding is at its genesis or at a point of appropriation interpretation whatever is a resentment
against life out of a fear of death. Let's say that's the case in Nietzsche. Uh, you find, I think, a
different appropriation of of this will toward understanding or this will this thing called
thinking which is is curiosity which is not a desire for for stabilization even if there's a recognition
that that stabilization is impossible but to embrace the thing as just another modality of life and to
then lighten it to to make it gay, to make it to make it a matter of laughing where well yeah the next
step isn't because of a failure or an insufficiency of the last step. Here's my only this is this would be
my other defending Hegel point, um, is that I think when I read Hegel I read someone who is so absorbed
in the complexity of the discourse, right? Like, you say, like, language speaks him, like it, you can feel
when you read him the language is like doing its own work and I think there is a joy to that even if
it's always inflected with sort of like seriousness labor dread anxiety, right? A lot of it is negatively
uh, inflected or intonated but I don't find him particularly invested in the stability of meaning
or the stability of representation even if those are articulated as symptoms of a couple of those key
faculties like the understanding or reason. I find the work explicitly invested in like, you know, like
with Derrida stuff, like sort of incoherence, um, uncertainty on an ontological level, like, and so I
feel like he's playing in a way that maybe he doesn't even recognize where it's you know but it doesn't
matter where it's like the the the text becomes so complex and so unwieldy but that to me is like a
productive unwieldiness. It's not for Hegel I don't think that produces anxiety I don't think he's like
we gotta we gotta tame the uncertainty of existence. He's following that thread to the point where it is
like it would be scary for some people and I'm sure it is scary for Hegel, um, but I think he makes that
step that leap more often than not then then Derrida in this essay gives him credit for, right? So you just
need to write the essay called or the book called Hegelian laughter. Yeah, exactly, yeah. And also let me
also say I don't doubt what you're saying and I don't think that what you just said is incompatible
with what Derrida's doing here with Bataille. I really don't, like, because you know, you you really
would have to say there isn't a Hegel, like, one unified, like, there isn't a Hegel, um, and yeah, it
becomes an index for something but that's again the project of like so you know the question that I would
pose to you is like all right, I believe thoroughly that that can be done and is available to be done not
simply by external work. It's available interior. So why do it, right? Like, why do that instead of doing
it to Barad which because it seems like in order to do that you require these people who are reading
Hegel badly, right? Like, you create a different kind of sounding board against which you can revert to the
positive or or affirmative Hegel or the Derrida's, right? You know, so in each case it's just a matter
of like, and I think that's Bataille's point. It's like that's the only game that's the only way
of engaging is by saying well it's not this and it's not that and it's not this other thing, you know
right right, um, yeah, so so yeah, like, I like is it possible in that case to say, um, you know, I'm
interested in Hegelian laughter but not because nobody else sees it and not because everyone takes them
to be somber and full of work and labor, right? Like, so the need to position it against something else.
Is sort of, you know, it's it's part of the same game. I mean, the more I read all of like
Foucault to Deleuze on Hegel, even when it's indirect, when they're just talking about, you know, humanism or
dialectics, I find it to be like a pragmatic cut. Like where it's like, I don't, I'm not going to take
offense to it. Like, I don't think Hegel would or why. Like, why would he? Like, this is, they they had to
make an intervention because of whatever, because of the pressures of the the moment, because of that
particular cultural moment, because philosophy was maybe they saw it hitting some sort of dead end,
right? So they felt a pressure and they made a decision and it just so happened that Hegel
for a few of these people, um, happened to be that hinge in order to kind of launch, um,
the the post-structuralist project or the variations of that project, so I don't think
that you don't need to defend. You don't need to be like, I got to recover Hegel from this attack,
you know, because it was like, that attack served its purpose in that moment and I don't think it's
unjustified, you know, it wasn't just, I mean, that's where to me like, you know, what Deleuze says of Nietzsche
in in the Nietzsche book is like, Nietzsche introduces a different tone into philosophy.
That's it, right? Like, and it's it's a tone of play, and it's not that Hegel's not funny. It's just a
question of like, well, which sitcom do you like? This, you know, this sitcom versus that sitcom, and and
that's the the sort of singular offering of any post-Hegelian or Plato. We could we could have
everything that we said in terms of Hegel, we could talk about in terms of Plato as another one of those
you know, massive figures who encapsulates all things, but you know, for me, for instance, why
would Plato be a more interest Plato would be a more interesting, um, figure to go to simply because
when I read it and I read the dialogues, it's funny, right? Like it's that fucking simple, right?
It's smart ass and funny. That is not to say that there's not humor in in Hegel. I just don't have
the coordinates for it, like jumping off the page at me, right? Like, and right, and whatever, that's that's
just a different way. I mean, neither are better. He's not laugh out loud funny, I'll tell you that.
You're not going to be just, you know, slapping your knee, just cracking up reading Hegel. It's not going
to happen. You can do that. You will do that with Nietzsche though. I mean, like, it's like totally different
writers, like just completely different sensibilities, you know? And it's almost like one is still like Hegel
almost reads like somebody who he it's almost like autistic, like the like, you know what I mean? Like just
the the the drive and the precision, but then the kind of weird, like sometimes lack of self-awareness of
his own tone, right? Like where he just shits on people and whole movements of thought and but so
it's like, and Nietzsche is like this, like a modern figure. Nietzsche is a particularly modern figure with
humor that holds up to like modern standards of humor, whereas Hegel's like just in this other era
where he's like he's kind of just caught in this moment where he doesn't he's not quite as accessible
um to sort of a modern sensibility, um, but again I don't I don't think that mean yeah like you're
saying I don't think that means that you couldn't do that sort of similar work with him, um, because
yeah, make it. I mean, give give me coordinates for reading Hegel. I mean, I'm fine with that. Like, it's
yeah, another way of saying this is that the level of the content there really isn't that much difference
between you know the Hegelian movement and the Nietzschean movement and I actually totally agree with
that right? Like that's where that's why that's why I'm writing a book on style is like, you know,
that that notion is it's like that that seems to be deeply important, and it's not anything that you
can point to, um, where he's like, ah, see there's Hegel being serious again, right? Like, you know, and and I
totally get uh the different different types of comedy in that regard. It's like there's right I I would
want to say like what do these folks have to say about comedy, but that's one thing, right? Like what
is what does Hegel say about laughter? I I don't have any idea, right? You know, I'm not even sure. I mean,
the way Derrida frames it it's like he doesn't even address it, like there's just not there's literally
no instance of of talking of joy or laughter in the Hegelian system and I mean yeah that is true I mean
it's it's sort of like Hegel's writing a tragedy, right? I mean it is it's it's somber, it's sort of
full of dread and anxiety, and those are the words you will see those exact words throughout the
Phenomenology of Spirit. You'll see dread, you'll see anxiety, um, you will never see the word laughter, I don't think
or like that's funny or what, you know what I mean? So right so yeah you are right I mean the styles are
I don't know, like, what does that mean though, like what, what do you draw from the fact that the styles
of engagement are sort of diametrically opposed even if the content or the terrain is similar
I mean it's just a record for me. It's just a recognition of difference and and it is just
sort of and I use each of those words recognition, uh, of difference, and also just to sort of like, hey
here, here are the playlists and there are different ones that are going to hook in different ways for
different ways of living, different dispositions, so it's like and so for me there isn't
it's kind of like, well, there are some nights that I want to listen to shoegazing emo music and
there are some nights where I want to listen, you know, like, not that it's simply a question of
subjective choice either but it's just a kind of dispositional inclinations. It's a way of just
saying like all of these things that we do are simply expressions of styles that are formed in the
relations of the things we do, right? Like, right, so right, so we reproduce a kind of labor of negativity
that one can find like even in Hegel and we reproduce that as an operation going
forward, like we are acting in the world when we read Hegel as the purveyor of the negative
um in some small way, right? Like and and there are other ways of doing that, you know, right, and one
can do it with Hegel or one can just read a different book. I'd want to go a little bit further than just
the different playlists and sometimes I like to listen to emo or hardcore jazz or or whatever else
because like well I mean or I want to stick with that metaphor a bit more because habituating oneself within those
genres of music makes different worlds makes different yes kinds of of life as well, and
and one thing that I see in in Hegel that I prefer to avoid is a kind of um suffocating totalizing
answer for for everything that only really leaves labor and somberness available. Like I don't think maybe I
don't think that he chooses those things as like his preferred go-to. It's like after he eradicates all
other possibility and direction that's what else is left, and what I love about I mean about Deleuze and
Nietzsche for sure but we're talking about Plato's there's a there's an agility in Plato's thinking
where it seems like at a he's always he is a lover of wisdom and that he's constantly chasing whatever he's
he's running off in whatever direction that he's been sort of catalyzed to head in and then
you know like then turns on a dime to go somewhere else based on someone's response or based on the
introduction of some other new thing. He's like the Steph Curry of concepts. He's the Steph Curry of
concepts for sure. Yeah, hey, go with Shaq where it's just like this is inevitable. I don't care if I'm
seven foot four, Rick Smith's, 250 pounds, I'm just going to labor at trying to stop him knowing that I
it doesn't matter what I do, he's averaging 36 points a game this series
yeah yeah I like that you not just ran with it you like took it the next step to give actual numbers
from a championship series where the Pacers were getting dominated like everything about that is
complete. That's great, which is why it was my Hegel example. Yeah, I mean I I do think I think you're
right uh but I also think Hegel is like well this is to your point like he's invested in his own
conceptual sophistication to the point where it becomes like a little bit solipsistic. Yeah, yeah
I mean that's an interesting way of saying it because one of the things that I've always liked
about Nietzsche is that he's a sloppy thinker, right? Like that and that's where the Derrida question for
me is a harder one because he's not right he's an incredibly precise
thinker and yet his precision is invested in in a kind of place. Yeah, like I mean it's it's a
it's a different kind of thing and that's what I mean that's why Derrida really appeals to me
I would say the same thing about Deleuze. Like to me Deleuze is a sloppy thinker
in that neat that's good Nietzschean tradition of like ah I'm just going to say different
shit sometimes I'm going to contract. He's not worried about the consistency of his terms. Yeah
or I mean or the other way of saying that he's yeah that he doesn't allow consistency to get in
the way of his precision and and rigor that I like that that sometimes the the word or the term even
though it's been used elsewhere has to be allowed to become something else and that actually that's
like either you can look at that as sloppiness or next level precision. Yeah, yeah
in the same way that you can look at like Steph Curry and be like all that herky-jerkiness is either wasted
sloppy movement or it's incredibly next level next level efficiency, right? Right, yeah, right
right I would maybe put Hegel on terms with like Kawhi at his best, you know, that kind of
here's what just happened, booboo ignored the last five minutes of our conversation
because he wanted to find the right NBA player the right player
thinking with yeah yeah you're gonna feast on this one conceptuality is something other than
itself; there's been a change in the image of thought. that's what it is, that's what it is
the internal structure of as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth it's divorced from the subject
thinking with thinking with thinking with thinking with thinking with